The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Good afternoon, everyone, again.
Today, our session is going
to be on motion perception
and pursuit eye movements.
Now, I want to remind you that
to our next class next Monday
is going to be a
whirlwind review.
And then the next
Wednesday we are
going to have the
midterm exam on what
we have covered so
far in the course.
And as I've mentioned already
to you a couple of times,
that is going to consist of
a series of multiple choice
questions in which
you have to circle
the appropriate choice
for each question.
Then the following week, which
is going to be November 28,
is when Chris--
AUDIENCE: October.
PROFESSOR: Huh?
AUDIENCE: October 28.
PROFESSOR: Sorry, October what?
AUDIENCE: 28th.
PROFESSOR: October 28.
Yeah, October 28--
that's when Chris Brown
is going to start the second
half of the course on audition.
So that is the general
plan at this point.
And again, I'm going to send
around an attendance sheet.
So just put your name on it and
send it around, please, for me.
Thank you.
All right, so I
think you're going
to find talking about motion
perception a lot of fun.
I have several demonstrations.
And it is certainly have
a very interesting topic.
And I'm going to highlight that
by first of all telling you
what we are going to cover.
And then we are going to talk
about the basic mechanisms
of direction selectivity
in the visual cortex.
So first of all,
as I've said, we're
going to talk about the neurons
in the brain that code motion.
I'm going to talk about it
mostly for in the cortex.
But I would also say a few words
about direction selective cells
that you find in the retina
that we had mentioned before.
All right, so we are going
to then discuss briefly
the possible
mechanisms that make
it feasible to process motion.
And then we are
going to look at what
happens when you make various
brain lesions in determining
how well you can process depth.
Then we're going to talk about
a very interesting topic, which
is structure for motion.
And then further
pursuing that, we're
going to talk about
apparent motion.
And then we are going to talk
about an interesting temporal
effect which is
called metacontrast.
And then we are going to talk
about optokynetic nystagmus,
where we link the visual input
to the generation of pursuit
eye movements.
Then that is accomplished by
the so-called accessory optic
system that I will
describe to you.
And that is also the topic
that, if you remember,
you will be writing a paper on.
Lastly then, we are
going to have a summary.
OK, so let's look first
at the neural responses
to motion in the cortex.
Now, one of the most
remarkable features
of the visual cortex and
extra cortical areas,
as I had already mentioned,
is that the majority
of cells in these areas
are direction selective,
meaning that they respond to one
particular direction of motion,
but not to the
opposite direction.
Now, this is extremely evident
in the visual cortex, where
the so-called simple cells,
virtually all of them
are direction selective.
So that's one of the
major transforms,
if you remember, of
the input that you
have from the lateral
geniculate nucleus that
goes to the cortex.
That input is just from single
cells, on and off single cells,
midget and parasol cells that
have circular receptive fields
that centers around antagonism.
And when they get
up to the cortex,
a transformation
takes place by virtue
of intracortical circuits
that turns these cells
into direction specific
ones and cells that
are orientation specific.
So let's look at this first
by starting with a method
so that you'll understand
exactly how this is done.
In this case, what
we are going to do
is we are going to
have a photo cell.
Let's just look at
the top one here,
A. You're going to have a
photo cell that responds both
to a light edge and a dark edge.
And so when this bar moves
across this photo cell,
it will activate it.
And what they're
going to do-- we
are going to move it
across in one direction.
And then we are going
to move it back across
in the other direction.
And this is shown here.
This is a time scale.
And it shows that when
this edge goes across,
it activates the photo
cell, gives it the beep.
And then when the
trailing edge goes across,
it also does the same thing.
So this is the
light edge response.
This is the dark edge response.
Now, when you're going
back the other way,
you're going to have,
again, the same arrangement.
In the opposite direction,
the light edge responds first.
And the dark edge
responds second.
Now we are going to make
a change so that it mimics
the organization of simple
cells in the visual cortex.
We're going to put
two photo cells, one
which responds to the light
edge and a dark one which
responds to the dark edge.
So now when this bar goes across
and activates these two photo
cells, what happens is, because
they are not all centered
exactly in the middle,
it takes a longer time
to activate the two successive
[INAUDIBLE] when the bar goes
across this way and
a short time when
it goes across the other way.
Now, the opposite happens
when you have a dark bar,
because then the dark
bar doesn't activate
the light sensitive photo cell.
It activities the dark one.
So it takes a little
longer to start that.
So that then shows you
the temporal arrangements
of these responses if
when the photo cells
are arranged in this fashion.
Everybody understand that?
OK, so now we are going
to do this for the real.
We are going to look
at a cortical cell.
And there are several different
subclasses of simple cells.
And the first
subclass we can refer
to as an S1, S for simple, OK?
So the simple cell
there is an example,
very similar arrangement.
Here's the receptive field
of the cell, undefined.
And you either put a light
edge across back and forth
or a dark edge back and forth.
This is the light edge response.
This is the dark edge response.
Now, you can readily
see what happens
here, which is quite remarkable.
The cell responds only
when the bar moves upward
across the receptive
field and does not
respond when it moves downward.
So this cell is over
100% direction selective.
Got it?
All right.
Now, the same thing happens
to the dark edge, all right?
And so this cell is one that
responds only to the dark edge,
OK?
In this case, it's
the trailing edge.
the leading edge.
Now, at the bottom
here, you draw out
what the receptive
field looks like.
This is in 10th of degrees.
And so this is pretty much
just the spatial response
of the cell.
And it only responds
in this direction.
There's nothing drawn
in the other way.
Now I'm going to show
you another cell, which
is going to be a
so-called S2 cell.
Now, this cell is different
in that it responds
both to the light
and the dark edges.
And the fact that they're--
in this case, a light bar,
in this case, a dark bar, the
fact that they're-- displaced
temporally mean that they're
side by side for the light
and dark responses
rather than overlapping.
And that, of course, is the
definition of a simple cell.
And so if you draw out the
receptive field of this cell,
once again, the cell is almost
100% direction selective.
And this is what its
response looks like in space.
Now we are going to
look at yet another one.
And this is going
to be a surprise.
It was certainly a surprise
when this was discovered,
because it's still
not understood
why we have these
kinds of cells.
Here is one-- you
can look at that--
that responds to a light edge in
this direction and a dark edge
in this direction, OK?
So both subfields are
direction selective.
But they're direction selective
in opposite directions,
as depicted here.
Now why on earth would you have
cells in the visual cortex that
respond selectively to
light and dark edges
in opposite directions?
That's something
you can contemplate.
There is no definitive
answer to that,
and so I'm not going to
belabor it any further?
Now what I can do is I can
provide you with a summary.
I showed you this one,
this one, and this one.
Now, you don't have
to worry about those.
But I would like you to
look at this last one, which
is a complex cell.
In a complex cell, the light
and dark edge responses
are in the same location,
space-wise, as shown here.
And this particular complex
cell that's a real cell
is 100% direction selective.
Now, it's true not
for all complex cells,
but the majority of
them that they too
are direction selective.
So I can safely
tell you that one
of the major transforms that
happens in the brain in vision
is to convert the signals
form the retina into direction
selective cells.
And therefore, we
can only surmise
that to have direction
selective cells is extremely
important for us to
be able to process
motion information in the world.
So now we are going
to move on and look
at extrastriate cortex.
And we already talked
briefly about MT and MST.
In these two areas, we have
even an stronger disposition
for cells to be
direction selective.
And here's an example
of a cell in MT--
in this direction of
motion, a vigorous response.
This is a cumulative response.
In the opposite direction, it
actually has some inhibition,
as you can see here and here.
Then if you recall from MST,
which is an area yet further
removed from area V1-- it's the
middle superior temporal area--
what you find is, again,
very strongly direction
selective cells.
Most of them-- maybe
not all of them,
but the overwhelming majority of
them-- are direction selective.
But they have much, much
larger receptive fields
than cells do in MT.
And as I've mentioned to you
before, one of the basic rules
is that as you
progress from the V1
to higher cortical
areas, the receptive
fields in these progressively
higher areas become
bigger and bigger and cover more
and more of the visual space.
So here you can
see this is shown
in terms of the
visual field here.
This is way out.
This is 20 degrees
just from here to here.
The receptive is
gigantic, actually.
And there's a beautiful,
very lawful arrangement
and even though many, many cells
feed into this particular cell
from earlier portions
of the visual cortex,
they maintain or get a specific
input from all of the cells
that have this
direction selectivity.
Now, whether this direction
selectivity is a product
of the input from the cells,
which have the same kind
of directions, like many,
many of these cells--
maybe 20 or 30 or 40
or 50 of them, OK?--
which have the same
orientation and direction,
or whether orientation and
direction selectivity are
created anew in MST is
something that can be debated.
It is still not 100% certain.
So the only thing we have
to worry about this time is
to realize-- maybe
not even worry.
That's too strong a
term-- is to be aware
that there is
prevalence of direction
selectivity in both MT and MST.
It's very beautiful and
very, very specific,
as you can see it
here, even when
you have a huge receptive field.
So that is the basic story then.
And now we can ask the
question, how on earth
is direction
selectivity created?
Now, there are several models
that have been proposed.
And most of these models-- I'll
show you a simple one just so
that you have a sense for it--
most of these models assume,
I believe correctly,
that you need
to have inhibitory circuits
that are selective for direction
to produce this specific
response in these cells.
Now, the amazing
thing about all this
is that already
in the retina you
have some cells that
are direction selective.
And these cells I'll
talk about a bit more
when we talk about the
accessory optic system.
These cells in the retina
are not very numerous.
In the rabbit that has
approximately 350,000 cells
in each retina-- can you
imagine a little rabbit?
And it has 350,000 cells.
We have a little
over a million, OK?
And among those 350,000
cells, about 7,000
are the so-called
cells of Dogiel.
And actually, I'll
come back to that.
And those are direction
selective cells.
So a very clever experimentalist
examined these direction
selective cells in the retina,
a fellow called Nigel Daw.
And he asked the
question, what can I
do to determine what
the mechanism is
of direction selectivity?
So he did an experiment
that sounds simple.
But let me tell you, it's a
very difficult experiment.
When you put your
electrode into the retina,
you can't see direction
selective cells.
So you're on a
hunting expedition.
So you keep recording from
cell after cell after cell.
And if indeed only
7,000 among the 350,000
are direction selective, it
will take you quite a while
before you manage to record
from a direction selective cell.
So it's a lot of very hard work.
So anyway, if you do that
when your hypothesis is
that some sort of inhibitory
mechanism is involved, then
you can do an
experiment and say,
well if it's inhibitory
mechanisms, probably
some sort of
GABAergic system, we
need to put some agent into the
retina that blocks inhibition.
We talked about that before,
that that can happen.
And so in this case,
what they did-- let
me come to that first.
Let me see.
Here we are.
I'll come back to the
others in just a minute.
What we have here is
one of these cells.
And we move in
this direction here
and in this direction for this.
And you can see that this cell
is very strongly direction
selective, maybe 100%,
but maybe 80% or 90%.
Then he injected picrotoxin
into the eye that blocks GABA.
And lo and behold,
direction selectivity
is virtually eliminated.
And then when picrotoxin
got washed out,
there was recovery, all right?
So now, on the basis
of this finding--
it's a beautiful finding-- it
was established that indeed,
inhibitory circuits play a
central role in giving rise
to direction selectivity.
And you can imagine that
in the course of evolution,
the pressures had to
be tremendous to create
these direction selective
cells, because the circuitry is
very complicated.
You have to create these
inhibitory neurons which
inhibit in a particular
direction rather than just
randomly.
So that's what was done.
And so I'll show you one
model that describes this.
You have a bunch of--
this is for the retina.
You have a bunch
of receptors here.
And they activate a
retinal ganglion cell here.
But they also connect with
an inhibitory interneuron
in one direction,
in that direction.
So now if you move a bar in
this direction, as shown here,
you get no response.
But if you move a bar
across the other way,
you get a vigorous response,
as shown by the action
potentials here.
So this is a fairly simple
model of creating direction
selectivity by virtue of
inhibitory interneurons.
So that then was also
examined in the cortex.
it was found that there
too inhibitory interneurons
play a central role when
direction specificity is
created in a cortical cell.
So that now makes me come
back to a further analysis
of the basic nature of motion.
Can we logically divide motion
into several types, or what?
And so it was proposed by a
wonderful scientist called
Wurtz at the National Institutes
of Health that he could--
he decided that
you can distinguish
between planar motion, circular
motion, and radial motion.
Planar motion is when
something moves straight.
That's what we've talked
about so far only.
And of course, you can do that.
In this case, he shows
four different directions.
But of course,
there'd be all kinds
of directions that are
not vertical or horizontal
but are diagonal.
And there are many,
many cortical cells.
Some of those actually I
showed you had orientation cell
activity that was at an angle.
So you have a huge number
of different angles.
And these cells
hypothetically then
would respond to planar motion.
Then you have another
type of motion,
which is called circular.
And let me tell you, when you
see circular motion, obviously,
if you were to be spun around
or something, you'd see it.
But it's not uncommon
to see something rotate.
So if you have a spinning wheel
or if you watch a tire rotating
in motion, that's
circular motion.
And so the hypothesis
is that there
should be cells in the brain
that selectively respond
to circular motion, either
clockwise or counterclockwise.
And lastly, of course, the
so-called radial motion--
and you encounter that
just about every day.
Whenever you drive,
you see trees.
Or if you're driving
out in the country,
you see trees going past you, so
to speak, as you drive forward.
And that would be motion
which would be outward.
Or if you were to
back up like this,
then you would get
this kind of motion
where things would
come together, OK?
So that kind of motion
is certainly one
that you need to somehow code.
And so another question
came up once he came up
with this hypothesis that these
different kinds of motion--
the question is, are there cells
in various parts of the brain,
especially in higher
areas like MST,
that are selective for these
three basic types of motion?
And so they began
to do an experiment.
And I'll show you some
summary data here.
Here is a cell when you
study planar motion.
And these are the eight
directions of motion
that were studied--
sorry, four directions
of motion on the top-- then the
circular one on the next two,
and the in and out
motion at the bottom.
This particular cell seems to
be specific for planar motion
from right to left.
Now here is a cell that is
selective to circular motion,
OK?
And lastly, here
is a cell that's
elective to radial motion.
So if you only had
recorded in your life
from three cells in
MST, and it happened
to be these three
cells, you would say,
ah, my hypothesis is right.
There are three
kinds of cells in MST
that respond selectively to
these three classes of motion.
So everything is incredibly
beautiful and logical.
But of course, that's not how
you do your experiment, is it?
The way you do
your experiment is
you record from
MST in this case,
and you record from
many, many, many cells.
And you test them
just like this, OK?
And if you do that, you
realize that this is just
an example of three
cells that were specific.
It was found that
40% of the cells
responded to all
three kinds of motion.
305 responded to
two types of motion.
And only 20% of
the cells responded
to one type of motion.
So therefore, these
cells, as is so often
the case in the visual cortex,
are not unique and specific
to analysis of one thing.
These cells can tell you
about all three of those.
And what happens in reality then
is that when something moves,
you activate thousands
of cells in MT, MST,
and visual cortex,
maybe tens of thousands.
And it's some sort of
complex relative activity
that then eventually gives
rise to the fact that you say,
oh, yeah I see planar motion.
Oh, yeah, I see a
circular motion,
or I see in and outward motion.
So it's not a
specific single cell
that tells you or gives
you that impression,
but it's the concerted
activity of thousands
of cells even for the
simplest of cases.
So that's the way it works.
It's a complex business.
And the idea that was
popular at one time,
namely that you have feature
detectors in the brain,
has become downgraded
progressively
with increasing research.
As I mentioned to
you before, when
we talked about to
extrastriate cortex,
the initial idea was when the
various extrastriate areas
had been discovered, that
each area specializes
in one particular thing.
And then it turned out
that that is not the case.
There may be shifts or
trends, but in each area,
many different
things are analyzed
and thousands and
thousands of cells
are active whose relative
activity is somehow
what gives rise to the
percept that you have.
All right, so that
then is the essence
of the layout of the
responses and the models
that this model that
[INAUDIBLE] told you about,
or something similar to this.
It may be a bit
more complicated.
And some people
have hypothesized
that there are temporal
delays necessary to produce
this thing.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
There was a 10% missing
in the breakdown.
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
Are you talking about this?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Well, that's-- 10%
of the cells were unclassified
or we're not
direction selective.
These they could with certainty
say what the situation was.
And maybe some of
those cells they
lost while that
we're recording from
or they didn't have any
particular direction
selectivity.
And because of that,
they couldn't come up
with 100%, of course, yeah?
Yes, you had a question.
AUDIENCE: It was
the same question.
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: It was
the same question.
PROFESSOR: Same question, OK.
Very observant-- good for you.
All right, so now we are
going to move forward
and we're going to look
at the effects of lesions
on motion perception.
One of the ready ways you
can assess to what extent
various higher
cortical areas play
a role in various
neural mechanisms
is to either reversibly
inactivate them
or to remove them by making
lesions and then determining
what happens.
And if you remember, I
talked about this a bit.
I told you, for example,
that the hypothesis that
was made initially about area
V4 is that it's a color area.
That was a single
function hypothesis.
And then it turned out that
when area V4 was removed,
it was found that there was
only a moderate to mild deficit
in color vision.
But there were all
kinds of other deficits
that we had discussed
in previous sessions.
So now we come to
the question about,
what about motion perception?
When we talk about emotion
perception, we of course
are dealing with
temporal things,
because motion involves
successive activation of cells.
And because of that,
it's also very important
to study how well we can process
rapid successive presentations
as, for example, in flicker.
And that brings me, of
course, to the story--
and we will talk about
that in a minute--
that in the olden days, when
movies were first invented,
the rate at which successive
frames were presented
was 16 Hertz, which was
fairly close to having
a sensational of
flicker, all right?
And because of
that, what happened
when a guy asked a
girl to go the movies?
How did the guy ask the
person to go to the movies?
Can anybody remember that?
That's an olden thing.
The guy would say,
hey, how would you
like to go to the
flicks tonight?
OK, you've heard that
expression, go to the flicks,
right?
Well, nowadays we are not
aware of flicks anymore.
And there are two
reasons for that.
Anybody know what
the two reasons are
why no one can see
clicks in the movies
and you no longer go
to the flicks anymore
but you go to the
movies instead?
Yeah?
What are the two reasons?
Anybody know?
OK, well, let me tell you.
The first is that the rate of
the number of frames per second
had been increased
to about 24, OK?
But that's still slightly
below the effusion.
OK?
You can still see some flicker.
So how do you get rid of it?
Well, let me tell you, some
incredibly clever guy--
some things are
really, really clever.
I'll tell you what this
person came up with.
He said, all right,
what we'll do
is we're going to create
a shutter which is round.
And it's going to
have one opening here.
And then we're going to
have a second opening here.
have a third opening here.
So this goes around.
And each frame you're
going to show three times.
And then as this goes around,
you go to the next frame,
and you show it three times.
So actually, if seeing frames
24 hertz, you see it 3 times 24,
OK?
But each frame is
shown three times.
Now, to be even more clever,
the way they did this,
they took two of these
circular shutters.
And one of them moved in
this direction and the other
in that direction.
They sort of equalized
from the center
out as the light was
expose from the projector.
So that then reduced
the rate of flicker.
So therefore, we can
next ask the question,
what is the flicker rate
at which you no longer can
see anything?
I mean, do you want
to see flicker.
Or do you not want to
see flicker, and so on?
And so experiments
were done, hundreds
of experiments in which
a psychologist studied
flicker rate, varying
contrast, varying color, doing
this, doing that, and then
varying the spatial frequency
and generating curves to
see what they look like.
So that's the process.
And so what we can do
next is to examine this.
And one way to do
this, for example,
just to give you
a sense, you can
have, for example, a
bunch of random dots,
just like we had for the
[INAUDIBLE] stereogram.
And this would be done
with a monkey, for example.
The monkey fixates.
And then you start something
in motion-- ready?-- like that.
And the monkey sees this and
has to make a saccade to it.
And when he does so, he gets a
drop of apple juice for reward.
And then what you can
very are two things.
You can vary the frequency.
I'm showing another one,
much higher frequency.
Bang-- the monkey goes
there and gets rewarded.
Or you can-- and/or,
actually-- you
can vary the contrast
of the display, OK?
So once you have a sense of when
you get fairly close to sort
of the edge of things, then
you can also vary the contrast.
So now let's ask
the question, what
happens when you remove area
MT and when you remove V4, OK?
So think about
that for a second.
And then I will show you
the actual data, all right?
OK, here we go.
Here is an example.
This is motion detection.
And here we vary percent
luminance contrast
at a fixed frequency.
You get the same
effect the other way.
I'll just show you this one.
And you can see very readily
that the V4 lesion caused
no deficit at all, but the MT
lesion produced a huge deficit,
OK?
So clearly this
establishes the fact
that area MT plays
a central role
in the processing of
flicker information
in being able to analyze
rapid temporal events.
And now we can ask
the next question.
What happens when you actually
do just stationary flicker,
all right?
So when you do
stationary flicker,
you can do that in two ways.
You can do an on
off flicker, or you
can do a flicker between two
colors, for example, all right?
And you can see why that
would be interesting.
Because if you do flicker
between two colors,
like red and green,
if area V4 were
important for color processing,
then a lesion in that area
should mess up that
kind of flicker.
So that's the way to do it.
So let me show you first of
all how you do this experiment.
Here we have it.
You have a bunch of LED's.
Why does one have LED's
instead of just doing
this on a monitor?
Any thoughts?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The frequency at
which those [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Very good.
The reason you do it is because
your typical frequency rate
is the alternating current
rate, meaning 60 Hertz.
Now, nowadays you
can of course buy
devices that can double
it or even quadruple it.
But back then it was
easier to do it this way.
And it still is, because
you can vary these flicker
rates in small amounts.
Now, each of these
LED's, actually,
for this particular
set of experiments,
is one that has both
red and green in it, OK?
So you can flicker between on
and off, let's say for green.
Or you can flicker between
red and green, all right?
So that's what we are
going to find out.
What happens when you do these
kinds of flickers, red green
as well as on and off?
And ask the question,
what happens
when you make, again a V4
lesion or an MT lesion, OK?
Now think about it
for a minute, as
to what you would
expect in terms
of the differences between on
and off and red green flicker
and possible differences
in the lesions
that cause a
deficit in this, OK?
All right, ready?
Here we go.
There is the flicker.
You can see that.
Now, the way that really works
is that the overall flicker--
I'll show it to you again--
is done in such a fashion that
the mean illumination level
is the same so that you cannot
tell the location of the
flickering LED on the basis
of a lumen exchange.
You can only tell on the basis
of the fact that it flickers
or it doesn't flicker, OK?
All right, so we are now
ready for the experiment.
And here it is.
On the right, I'm showing you
a green on and off flicker.
And you can see that there's
no deficit at the V4 lesion,
but a gigantic, absolutely
gigantic deficit at the MT
lesion site.
And then very surprisingly-- to
some people at least who were
convinced that V4
is a color area--
when you do that for a red
green flicker, first of all,
notice that the flicker rate
that you can detect is much
lower-- OK, this is the ratio of
the flicker, much lower, OK?--
than it is for the
on off flicker.
And secondly, again, there's
no significant deficit
with the V4 lesion.
But there's again a major
deficit with MT lesion.
So area MT is
essential for being
able to process both red and
green flicker as well as on
and off flicker, all right?
So bear that in mind as we
are going to now progress
to the next stage of the
experiment-- set of experiments
I should say.
And the next step I'm
going to talk about
is structure from motion.
And that one is a very important
attribute that we have.
We can reconstruct structure
by see nothing but motion.
And I'm going to show
you an example of that.
OK, let me tell you,
this here actually
is a scene, a made-up
scene, that's outside.
And somewhere in here
we have ladybug hiding.
But the ladybug
is not in motion.
And you know, ladybugs have
these spots on their back.
And there's a ladybug here.
And I'm going to tell you that
there's a monkey watching this,
hoping that he could catch
the ladybug to have it,
because he loves
to eat ladybugs.
Are you ready to catch her?
OK, here we go.
Ready?
The ladybug after a while got
tired of just sitting there
and began to move.
And that's a dead
giveaway, because you
have all these
cells in your brain
that selectivity see
motion and flicker.
Are you ready?
Here we go.
There's the ladybug.
See her?
OK, so the monkey is happily
eating away the ladybug,
all right?
So here is a good example
of how incredibly useful
motion information
is that you have
in these visual cortical areas.
Now, I would bet that if this
monkey had had his MT removed,
he wouldn't have been able
to catch that ladybug.
Now, another set of
experiments carried out,
beautiful experiments,
were carried out
by a fellow called
Johanson-- I think
that was in Sweden-- who did a
very clever set of experiments.
He wanted to analyze how well we
can process motion information
and derive structure from it.
And what he did was that he
put little teeny little light
bulbs on about 13 points
in the human's body.
He put some here on the
elbows, put some at the hand,
put some at the head, and
so on down, 13 of them.
And then he turned
off all the lights,
so the only light was that
little spot of light that
was on these 13 spots of
light that were on the person.
And then he took a
movie to see what
happened when this
person started to walk.
And he discovered
something amazing,
that we are incredibly capable
of reconstructing shape
from minimal motion information.
So are you ready?
OK, here we go.
So there it is.
There are your 13
little spots of light.
And now I'm going
to set it in motion.
Ready?
So what do you see?
You see a person walking on
this very minimal information.
And you can even tell--
who would say it's a male
and who would say it's a female?
Those of you who say it's
a male, raise your hands.
OK, it's virtually everybody.
Right, very good.
Now, so what he did which
I don't have a movie of,
which is quite
remarkable, is that he
took a couple, a
male and a female
and had them arranged in
exactly the same way-- each
had 13 of those bulbs--
and had them dance.
And when you looked at
that, you had no trouble
telling which was the male
and which was the female.
Amazing.
So we are able to reconstruct
a tremendous amount of form
detail on the basis of
extremely limited information
about motion.
All right, so that
then ends that session.
And we're going to go next to
what is called apparent motion,
all right?
So you're going to have various
forms of apparent motion
I'm going to tell you about.
And the first one is that if you
show these two dots, if I flick
them back and forth, you
have a very strong sense
that the thing is going
back and forth, right?
You don't see one, two,
going on and one going off,
because of the right
temporal succession.
But you see them as just
jumping back and forth.
So now what we can do--
we can enlarge on that
and carry out a series of
experiments on the bases
which can make some inferences
as to whether areas V4
or MT are contributing to this.
So this is going be fun for you.
And I want you to
pay close attention.
Now, in this kind of
experiment when it was done,
first, this stayed
on all the time.
And these two dots
came on first.
And then these two
dots came on second.
Now, if you do that, you can see
either of two types of motion.
You can either see what
we call zigzag or seesaw.
Seesaw is going to look
like that, obviously,
and zigzag like this, OK?
So that's what I'm
going to show you.
And once I set
this in motion, you
will see it one
way or the other.
Then if you see
it's, say, seesawing,
you can take your finger
and move it horizontally
back and forth on top, say.
And then in short order you're
going to be seeing this.
You can reverse the sense
of motion, all right?
So are you ready for that?
OK, so here we go.
If you see it one
way or the other,
try to move your finger back and
forth to change it to see it.
If you see it horizontally
moving, move it vertically.
If you see it vertically,
move it horizontally.
And then you can see it shift.
Everybody able to reverse it?
Well, keep doing it.
And you should have no
trouble reversing it
if you move your
finger back and forth.
This is a bistable situation.
And people can readily
see the switch.
OK, most of you
seeing it switching?
All right.
So now we can ask a
whole bunch of questions.
And the way to put this
question in general
is we can ask, is first of
all, is this something that
happens locally, or does
it happen everywhere
when you're looking?
So how can you do that?
So let me show you.
What they we do here instead is
we can put up a bunch of them,
OK?
And they're quite far
apart from each other.
And depending on
how close you are,
they may be as far
as a centimeter
apart in the visual
cortex for the activation.
So now what we're
going to do is we're
going to move them back and
forth just like I did before.
And the question
that you want to ask
yourself-- am I going
to see these all
move the same way vertically,
say, or see all of them
move horizontally, OK?
So here we go.
Are you ready?
Basically, the rule is that
they all move the same way.
And then they shift.
Again, you can use your
thumb or your forefinger.
And if you manage
to make it switch,
they all will switch
at the same time.
OK, everybody manage that?
All right, so now the rule is
that even though the activation
is very far apart in
V1 from here to here,
there's some organizing
principle that
makes you see everything
a particular given way.
And they shift.
They all shift.
Now, that's a very
interesting arrangement.
And you can wonder,
what is there
that can tell the visual
cortex how to see it and insist
that you got to see
it the same way?
Now we can move on.
And you can ask the
question-- so far,
what I've shown you is
they're all the same-- sorry.
That's my fault.
They are all the same size.
And they are geometrically
arranged, OK?
So now what happens if
instead, we do it differently
and we make them different
sizes and random locations?
What happens under
these conditions?
Now think about it for a minute.
And then I'm going
to show it to you.
And once again, even though
they're different sizes,
different locations,
they all go the same way.
And when they shift--
again, use your forefinger
to try to make it shift.
And when they shift, they all
shift at the same time, OK?
All right, so now we
can move on and ask
some interesting
additional questions.
We can ask the
question, how important
is color information for you to
see it go one way or the other?
All right?
OK, so to do that, here we have
the top two are colored red
and the bottom two
are colored green.
Now we're going to move
these back and forth.
And the question is, will you
see them move horizontally
because of the color
information or what?
So the question
is, again, are you
going to see zigzag or seesaw?
OK, are you ready?
And you can readily see if,
again, you can readily shift it
again with your forefinger,
that color doesn't seem
to be an important determinant
of the direction in which
the apparent motion
will take place.
Everybody follow that?
Well, now think about that.
How can we do this
experiment to be
more convinced that
color for some reason
doesn't seem to be important
in how we see apparent motion?
Well, let me tell
you how you do it.
Here is an example.
Here we have again four rows
and four columns, all right?
And the first, one A and C,
the colors are horizontal.
And in the second one, B
and D, they are vertical.
So if color plays
a role, we should
be able to see these, the
first and the third rows
go in one direction
and the second
and the fourth row go
in the other direction.
So let's examine that.
Ready?
And you can see that they're
all going the same direction
anyway.
When they switch, they
switch in the same direction,
meaning that indeed you pay no
attention to the color itself,
OK?
Some mechanism is
involved in which
the apparent motion
you see does not
play a significant
role in color.
Now we can do another
experiment and see
what happens when
instead of colors, we
use small shapes,
X's and O's which
are horizontal in the
first and the third row
and vertical in the
second and the fourth row.
Will this succeed in breaking
up the unity of apparent motion?
So here we go.
Ready?
And you still see
them all the same way,
meaning that you
don't pay attention
to the small
differences in shape.
OK, so now what I
have shown you so far,
remember, has something to do
with the midget and the parasol
systems for the test.
The midget system can
process fine detail.
And the midget system
can process color.
The parasol system does
not process fine detail
and does not separately
process color.
So we'll come to
that in a minute.
Now let's ask the next question.
What happens if
you vary the size?
OK, again, the first and
third row, the size difference
is horizontal.
And the second and fourth
row, it's vertical.
OK, so let's see what happens.
Here it's a bit unclear, OK?
So as you see, some
of them go one way.
Some go the other way.
And some of you may see
it all go the same way,
depending on how far you are.
So let's change the ratio
so it's much, much bigger.
And if you do it now,
what you see is dramatic.
You see horizontal motion
in the first and third rows
and vertical motion in the
second and fourth rows.
Everybody see that?
OK, so we can enhance
on this maybe a little
bit by adding these together,
adding size and color
and shape, quite large
differences in size and shape
and color.
Then if you do this,
you will indeed
have fully succeeded in
breaking up the unity of motion,
with the first and third
rows going horizontally
and the second and fourth
rows going vertically.
Now then there's one
other important factor
that we need to
consider about this.
And that has to
do with proximity.
So in this case, what
we're doing now--
in the first and
the third rows, we
have the horizontal dots
closer to each other.
he second and fourth rows, we
have the vertical dots closer
to each other.
So if you do that, you're
going to ask the question,
how important is proximity?
And if you do that, you
don't see much so far.
But now what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to make the
difference even greater, OK?
The first and third are
very close horizontally.
And the second and fourth
are very close vertically.
If you do that,
you readily can see
that indeed the first and
third rows move horizontally
and the second and fourth
rows move vertically.
So proximity is a
very important factor.
And so that then brings me
to an interesting question
that probably none of you
have given much thought.
But I will make you
more aware of it.
The fact is that
when you see movies,
you very often see a car or
a chariot or something move
forward, but the wheels
are going backwards.
And you certainly
do that when you
watch those endless ads
on television about cars.
And you see the wheels going
backwards most of the time.
And the car is going forward.
And some of you say,
well, why would I
buy a car whose wheels
are going backwards?
So at any rate, let's
examine that question.
And what I'm going
to do first is
I'm going to show you a movie.
Ready?
This a famous movie, Ben-Hur.
You've probably seen it.
Look at the wheels
going backwards.
Can you see that?
Now, of course since I have
given this a lot of thought,
it drives me nuts when I see
wheels going backwards when
the chariot or the
car goes forward.
All right, so now
the question is,
why do we see wheels going
backwards in the movies
or on the ads on television,
whereas when you see it
in the real, you never
see them going backwards?
Well, remember that when you
look at a movie or television,
you always see apparent motion.
You never see real
motion on television,
never see real
motion in the movies.
You're not aware of
it, but you don't.
You only see apparent
motion because you
have successive frames
in each of which there
is a specific, say, if
it's wheels, rotation, OK?
So let's look at
that analyze this.
So I'm going to show you a
wheel that is rotating slowly.
Are you ready?
it's a very brief.
OK, you can see that wheel
is going forward, right?
Now I'm going to show you
the same and arrangement.
But I'm going to
have it move fast.
Ready?
Ready, go.
That time you saw it
go backwards, right?
OK, so let's analyze this.
What happens when
you have slow motion?
Let's imagine that
the red line is
designating one of the spokes.
Then if it moves
slowly, the next frame
is going to show that displaced
only a little bit from the red,
and so on.
And because of that, you're
going to see forward motion.
But now if what you do instead
is moving fast, what happens
is that this spoke here
is going to be closer
to this one in the next frame.
And because of that--
of course, that's
all of them all the
way around-- you
will see them go backwards,
because of the principle
of proximity that I showed
you with the apparent motion
of the four moving dots.
OK, so that then explains to
you why you see wheels rotating
backwards in the movies
and on television.
And it's due to a
fact of the proximity
of successive
elements, in this case,
spokes that are rotating as the
picture is taken with a camera.
All right.
So now I'm going to come
up and tell you briefly
about another very
interesting phenomenon that
is closely related to motion.
When two successive
stimuli are presented,
there can be an interaction
between them, all right?
And in a famous series of
experiments back in the 1930s,
they did what is called a
metacontrast experiment.
First, a disc was
presented like this.
And then it was
followed by a ring.
And they shared the
same contour, OK?
This is it, OK?
So now what you
could do-- you could
vary the temporal
interval between them.
So if you present these
two simultaneously,
since they have
overlapping contours,
that's all you would see.
But then if you present
them sequentially-- ready?
Like that, then the
question is, to what degree
did you see that first one?
So let's look at that.
And I want you to
pay close attention
to when I present
this to you, OK?
Are you ready?
You're going to do it
now so that they're only
60 milliseconds apart, OK?
Here we go.
You barely see the
first one, right?
You could just
barely make it out.
But it's not gone.
Some people thought it
would cause it to be gone.
But that's not the case.
So what you do then
is the following.
If you fixate on
the red cross, I'm
going to present the stimuli.
And I want you to tell me
which of the two stimuli
I present is
preceded by the disc.
Ready?
Could you tell?
Which one, left or right?
Left, good.
Again, repeat.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Ready?
AUDIENCE: Left.
Left.
PROFESSOR: OK, very good.
So the fact is that when you
present two side by side where
one of them is
preceded by the disk,
you can tell which
one came first.
So somehow this didn't
obliterate your ability
to see it.
Now, the other
interesting fact is
that if now you flicker
back and forth between them,
at equal rates, you
see both equally.
So therefore, what happened
is you did not truly
obliterate the percept.
You just somehow weren't
too much aware of it
because of the
temporal offset between
the successive presentations.
Now, you can do this
slightly differently.
Instead of having two stimuli
that do not overlap but have
adjacent contours,
we can overlap them.
So here I'm going to show
you something and ask you
what you see.
Ready?
What do you see?
A big disk?
OK?
There it is.
Now I show it to you.
As to what I really
showed you, was first
I presented a dim small disc
followed by a brighter higher
contrast bigger disc.
And that obliterated the
perception of the first one.
And that is truly obliterated.
And the interesting experiment
you can do in this regard--
you can do this interocularly.
In other words, you can
present one of the stimuli
to the left eye and the
other to the right eye.
If you do that, you don't
get a masking effect.
But if you go back and
do the metacontrast,
you still get the
same pseudo blockage
without actually
eliminating it, but sort
of making you less aware
of the first stimulus.
OK, so now if one
examines this, the way
to do the experiment
right is you
vary the temporal offset
between the two stimuli.
And when this was
done systematically
with the brightness masking
that I showed you later,
secondly, what happens is that
the effect rapidly declines.
It's the biggest
when the two are just
right next to each other.
By contrast, when you
do the metacontrast,
the biggest effect is when
they're about 62 to 100
milliseconds separated,
because that's
when apparent motion
is most effective.
And then if you do an experiment
to see where this happens
for the brightness
masking, here's
what happens in the retina
recording from a cell.
This is a dim stimulus,
a smaller response,
and with a longer latency.
And the mask alone will
get a much shorter response
and a much more vigorous one.
And then when you systematically
vary the temporal interval
between the two of
them, you can see
when the interval becomes short.
The second stimulus
obliterates the first one
because it's faster and
it has a bigger response.
So this explains what
happens, because it happens
in the retina by
virtue of transmission.
And the rule of the fact that
the rate at which information
is transmitted from
the four receptors
to the retinal ganglion
cells is contrast dependent.
The higher the contrast,
the faster the response.
All right, so now
does anybody have
any questions about the
masking or the metacontrast
that we talked about so far?
All right, in that
case, we are now
going to move on and talk
about another important motion
perception effect which links
one to eye movement generation.
And that falls into
the category of
so-called optokinetic nystagmus.
So how do you study
optokinetic nystagmus
at the very basic level?
Well, the way you study it is,
for example, in the olden days,
you could take a large
lamp shade like that
and put vertical bars
on int on the inside,
have a person have
his head inside.
And then you rotate
the lamp shape
so that the bars go
across like that.
Or you can do that
more simply nowadays.
You just go put a bunch of
vertical bars on a monitor
and have them drift.
And the person is
asked to look at it.
So when the person
does that, what you get
is the so-called
optokinetic nystagmus.
It has two phases.
It has a fast and a slow phase.
The fast phase is a saccade, a
resetting saccade, if you will.
So you watch an edge.
You follow it.
And then once it gets
to the periphery,
you make a saccade back
and you watch the next one.
And you keep doing it.
And this shows you the
three different rates.
Now, this is quite an
interesting mechanism.
And it was determined that
an important contribution
to executing these kinds
of eye movements, which
is very important, because
when you track anything, if you
track a bird of something,
you keep your eye on it.
And then once it gets past
you, make this a saccade back
and take the next
bird and track it.
So that's the mechanism.
And it's been shown that
several neural mechanisms play
a role in it.
And one of those belongs to
the so-called accessory optic
system, which has
those cells of Dogiel
in the retina that
connect to it.
So we're going to look at that.
Some beautiful work has
been done about that.
But before I do
that, let me show you
a very interesting factor.
Here is a typical
optokinetic nystagmus
induced by a drifting vertical
set of bars at various rates,
as you can see here.
And this is a rabbit.
And in the rabbit, what you have
is a left eye and a right eye.
And you can activate them
separately, as shown here.
Now, a remarkable
discovery that was made
is that the accessory
optic system-- that there's
a primary role in
generating this optokinetic
nystagmus that is
found initially
in among the cells of Dogiel,
of which in the rabbit, as I've
said, there are about 7,000
out of 350,000 in the eye.
And it was found-- which
was incredibly surprising--
that this system originating
with the cells of Dogiel,
the cells of Dogiel themselves
get input only from ON bipolar
cells, OK?
So what can we do to prove
that this system here indeed
is one that is activated
by the cells of Dogiel,
since the cells of
Dogiel in the rabbit
get input only from
the ON bipolar cells?
Anybody can think
of an experiment?
What did I tell you about
the on and off systems
and how they can be manipulated?
Anybody remember?
Now, see you've got
to remember facts.
And one of the facts was I told
you about what happens when you
use 2-amino-4-phosphonobutyric
acid, APB.
Anybody remember that?
If not, you'd better
study it, because there
are going to be questions on
that on the exam, of course.
OK, so if you put
APB into the eye,
you block the ON bipolar cells.
And therefore, if
only ON bipolar cells
feed into the cells
of Dogiel, you
would expect that if you
block those bipolar cells,
you should eliminate the
optokinetic nystagmus
in the eye that had been
injected, if it's indeed true
that the cells of
Dogiel are involved, OK?
So that's a
beautiful experiment,
because it's a definite one
if indeed the data come out
the way one had hoped.
And guess what happens?
Here are the data.
The red ones are
from the eye that
had been injected with APB.
You know, you
blocked the ON cells.
And hence, you
blocked the responses
of the cells of
Dogiel, all right?
So this is a rather nice,
luckily definitive, experiment.
Now, the curious thing is, if
you did the same experiment
in a monkey, you
would get nothing.
Here you do the same
experiment in a monkey.
Here is your OKN.
And here is when you put in APB.
And still after putting
in APB, the monkey
still does
optokinetic nystagmus.
That's because the rabbit
is a very unusual species.
And god only knows
why it happened
that only On bipolar cells
fed into the cells of Dogiel.
In the monkey, you get
both ON and OFF cells
feeding into the
cells of Dogiel.
All right, so now another
interesting factor
that I want to
mention just briefly
is that it's indeed is true
that the feedback mechanism is
essential for you to do
optokinetic nystagmus right.
Here is a monkey in which
one eye has been immobilized
and the other eye is normal.
So if you look at the
normal eye and you
move a set of vertical
bars very slowly,
this is what your
optokinetic nystagmus
looks like-- just a
very slow tracking.
But then if you do the same
thing in the mobilized eye,
and you, of course, record the
eye movement of the other eye
which is blocked, what you
get is a tremendously rapid
increase in the
pursuit movement.
This can be called open loop.
And this can be
called closed loop.
Now, the mechanism
involved here is
that your intent is to track.
But when you realize--
or not you realize,
but the brain realizes.
You're not even aware
of it-- that you are not
following fast enough to
keep up with the motion
of the vertical bar,
you order the eyes
to move faster,
faster, and faster,
and faster and faster,
and it practically
runs away like crazy.
And it still-- of course,
because the eye is
immobilized-- hasn't been able
to catch up to the moving bar.
So this further highlights the
importance of this mechanism.
And it has to be a closed
loop system, obviously,
for it to work properly.
So there's a
feedback telling you
whether you had correctly
tracked something.
OK, so now I come to
the last point today,
which is now the mechanism
that is involved in the motion
analysis of accessory
optic system.
I'll talk about
this only briefly,
because this is going to
be part of your paper.
All right, now, they
remarkable discovery
that was made--
amazing discovery--
was that when people recorded
from the cells of Dogiel,
they found that these cells
come in three different types
with three different axes of
orientation, these three axes.
And when that was
first found, people
said, what on earth is going on?
Why would we have
three like that?
I would have thought
we'd have four,
vertical and horizontal
at least, or something.
So this was really puzzling.
But then they began to
do some more experiments.
And they made a truly
remarkable discovery.
And their discovery
is shown here
in a summary diagram of
the accessory optic system.
OK, here are these
cells of Dogiel
with the three axes of
direction selectivity.
They respond to rather
slow motion velocities.
So what happens
here-- I'm not going
to go into detail, because
you're going to, as I say,
report on this.
But let me tell you
about the essence of it.
The cells of Dogiel project into
the so-called terminal nuclei.
And then they project
up to the cerebellum.
And from the cerebellum,
there's a projection down
to the vestibular nuclei.
And then it was found,
as it was known already,
that the semicircular
canals come
in three orientations
which are the same as those
of the orientations of
the cells of Dogiel.
And so then they feed into
the ocular motor system
to move the eyes so as to
keep the eyes in accurate
contact with whatever
you're intending to look at.
So that is the very essence
of the accessory optic system.
And I just thought
this will help you
in putting your paper together.
All right, so now I am
ready to summarize for you.
First of all, motion
has been classified
into several different types
that include planar, circular,
and radial.
And one thing we talked about
earlier that I mentioned here,
but I didn't mention
in this presentation--
when we talked about
depth perception,
we talked about motion parallax.
That's a very important
aspect of motion analysis.
Then secondly, the
majority of cells in V1
and most cells in MT are
directionally selective, OK?
And an addition which
I mentioned earlier
is that they also show
velocity selectivity.
Some V1 cells respond
to different directions
of movement for light and dark
edges, like the S2 type cell
I showed you.
And some cells are sensitive
to differential velocities
of movement, which
I didn't show.
Then the accessory
optic system that
begins with the retinal ganglion
cells of the cells of Dogiel
form three axes of
direction selectivity
that correspond
to the three axes
of the semicircular canals.
And they are involved in
generating pursuit eye
movements for image
stabilization.
Then one of the most important
tasks of motion analysis
is motion parallax,
as it provides
information about depth.
Motion cues can provide
important information
for object recognition,
often referred
to as structure for motion.
And stationary
stimuli that flicker
with various temporary signals
induce apparent motion,
of which I showed you
a lot of examples.
And then we talked about
metacontrast masking,
which is a phenomenon
that occurs
when two stimuli share contours.
And when they're presented with
an interval which corresponds
to apparent motion, you tend
not to see the first one.
Lastly, brightness masking
arises with overlapping stimuli
appearing in rapid succession.
And this does not occur with
interocular presentation,
proving that it's a
record of phenomenon.
And it has to do with the fact
that the velocity with which
a stimulus activates the retinal
ganglion cells and hence,
of course, the cortex, is much
much slower with dim stimuli
then with bright ones.
And so bright
stimulus, in a sense
overtakes the responses
to a dim and weak stimulus
when the two successive
presentations are very rapid.
OK, so that's the
end of it here, OK?
And I'll show you one
more motion effect.
Ready?
All right, so that is
the story for today.
And next time,
you're going to have,
as I said, a rapid
summary of what
we have covered in the
first half of this course.
And then the following
Wednesday, we
are going to have the multiple
choice exam for the midterms.
OK, thank you kindly.